astralis was once the greatest dynasty
in cs go history he goes down with the
max 70 can't make it happen finally
pasha coming in with a refract but he's
down the bomb has been picked up by
dupreeh they get the spray neal takes
one
there
as they win the first major championship
16-14 against fluttershy
the best of all time until grand slam it
destroys their roster featured some of
the best players in cs go and for years
no other team even came close to them
flashed he's gonna get that shot and
that has to feel a little bit going out
middle of the air but if he takes every
single one astralis changed the way cs
go was played forever astralis grenading
their way into overtime no other cs go
team was as successful as astralis but
in 2021
that all came crashing down
it's definitely disappointing and
i have my workout out for me and we need
to uh we need i need to address it
because it's not good enough
heading into the 2019 berlin major all
eyes were on astralis despite a
relatively shaky year they were still
considered one of the best teams in cs
go and once astralis got rolling they
reminded everyone why they'd been so
dominant for so long they went
undefeated in the playoffs crushing
liquid and defeating avangar to win
their fourth major
ladies and gentlemen give it up once
again for your champions astronauts
[Applause]
once and for all astralis cemented
themselves as the greatest cs go team of
all time
and now every supposed strcs go team was
asking themselves the same question
how do you beat astralis you see
astralis shared the quarter-final stage
in berlin with some unexpected company
teams like renegades nrg and ivangar
beat out established legends like ends
vitality and na'vi
astralis continued dominance showed that
relying on star power from players like
zyu and simple was not enough
teams realized that if you wanted to
beat astralis you had to become astralis
a well-oiled machine with no weak links
astralis changed the way teams were
built forever and ultimately that was
their undoing once 2020 hit those
changes happened immediately complexity
two on two they have a slight health
advantage but against these weapons for
australis it might not matter oh
he had the hell for it but now he's been
taken out and sip just trying to buy
time flank it around blame it hunting
him down he's gonna turn for it
immediate defuse he's right there with
the kid oh my god i can't believe it's
16 and 12. complexity taking down
australia
[Applause]
a revamped complexity lineup knocked
astralis out of blast the first
tournament of the year it was more of
the same at the iem world championship
where na'vi now equipped with perfecto
two owed astralis and won the tournament
glaive now fully committed towards
outside and they seem to know it as well
piece by piece navi are finding this
16th round no problem at all through the
flames two three will retreat 25 hp call
it done and there it is 1605 a very
convincing 2-0 there the best-looking
navi i've ever seen against the world's
number one team there they made them
look average they made it look foolish
at times and it's a team effort as well
this wasn't just a simple show every
single player on navi showed up here in
the semi-final astralis showed signs of
life at the rio major qualifier but the
good news stopped there
the global pandemic changed life as we
knew it obviously lands couldn't happen
so the rio major was delayed and then
eventually cancelled as we moved into
the online era and that caused a new
unexpected problem for astralis burnout
astralis long time igl glaive took a
break to focus on his mental health a
few weeks later zipnics followed suit
citing similar issues
the next few months were rough without
their core intact astralis struggled but
since the major got cancelled the boys
didn't miss out on too much and by
december they were whole again to close
out the year in a big way astralis still
invested still interested in dupre with
the quick flick gets rid of a leash
at the ramp is very very low he's doing
damage but they've lost him and his
twists alone in the 1v3 dupree with the
kill and astralis grab that 16th they
take the third and that does mean that
they've done it my oh my in a year that
was dominated by every team except the
danes the one true kings have retaken
their throne although astralis finished
off 2020 with a big win at the iem
global challenge things just looked
different even when they were whole they
just didn't seem as dominant as they
were before the online era it didn't
help that other teams were finally
putting up real results and on top of
that onliners were rising up and making
a name for themselves often by pushing
astralis to their limit and by the time
that 2021 rolled around it was clear
that the greatest team in cs go was on
the decline
400
000
on the line for this retake that is the
difference
and it's all on glaive low hp for three
navi they've got it navi have done it
your blast global finals grand champs
and i don't think there's much left here
magisk in a one versus two and here's a
flashbang and that is all that he has no
kits or anything else so
this is gonna be a rough crossfire to
try and break he runs right onto the
side gets one turns and taps them with a
headshot and it is big 16 to eight as
they drop astralis down in to the
showdown and knock them out of the group
here what an amazing performance here
from the fourth fest team in the world
taking out number one
duprey out devices found something maybe
this monster
with the awp can find another and make
it slightly more realistic sanji is
tucked in
a man possessed though he'd have to do
it all and he has adjusted into sanji
three more fertas pro have it
just have to pull across the line one
more will do one frag
and he's running out of time as well
doesn't hit it vertus pro baby they've
done it they're into the semi-finals and
they send australis home all the big
names knocked down on their way
iem calavita 2021 it's got a very
different flavor astralis lost again and
again they were a shell of their former
selves they tried experimenting with
bubsky as a sixth man but the results
still didn't change
during the course of 2021 the magic
slipped away from astralis there's
something wrong right now when the
astralis came i think magic said it a
little bit yesterday in the interview he
didn't mean to give away as much as he
did but the confidence right now on the
individual skill level from their
stylish place is nowhere near where it's
supposed to be they are where we are
where and we see the consequences right
here and things only went from bad to
worse new young stars rose up to help
dig astralis grave
an astralis conceding take a breath
you're reconfirming it only more as the
frags do come in a harrowing loss but a
spectacular victory
headshots from magisk delaying the
inevitable it's confirmed 16 to 2.
that will get them loud that'll get them
out of their seats fury a domination
against astralis the old guard fall
and the new breed
are in the semi-finals a three versus
two here in the aftermath magus with the
one kill good lineup good crossfire and
now it's manchester versus sip do you
know where he is he's right in that
corner he's definitely already been
spotted jumps up and gonna be the flick
taking him out and that is gonna be the
second map in favor of og
absolutely spectacular in overtime and
mantu tougher the ball towards the end
what a performance from him oh gee with
the new lineup and they are looking so
hot right now the 16th seed has taken
down the first seed fully kicked things
off in the showdown and if that doesn't
sum it all up the struggles the trials
that astronauts are going through right
now the king of clutch himself zip makes
you thinking once upon a time there's no
way he loses this and yet here we have
it all of a sudden astralis the team
that won four majors the greatest
dynasty in cs go history was at rock
bottom
and then
the unthinkable happened
what's up guys
i sleep in
one
time bro i didn't take the day off i
still planned on streaming and
device leaves astralis to nip
everyone knew that astralis had to make
a change but even now it's pretty
shocking to think about how device left
the team he led for almost a decade but
the move made sense astralis clearly
weren't working anymore and things
weren't going to go back to the way they
were before the online era device didn't
become a four-time major champion by
sitting around and waiting for things to
improve
he left astralis because he wanted to
win again at least from where i come you
are
maybe five steps ahead
i mean how he practiced prepare
working with danny i spoke a little bit
with him as well so just really excited
to get going i think that as you also
said as jonah said i think we have the
possibility to
like dominate a lot of teams be the best
in the world nip fans may have loved the
news but for astralis this hurt they
didn't just lose their statistically
best player they lost a part of their
identity
they lost a brother
well obviously nikolai i know that you
have
you have made up your decision and
i respect it fully and i'm i'm gonna
start crying now because it's actually
quite emotional
how do you put it out i mean i respect
everything you've done and what we've
been through
and
yeah i mean
i wish you the best going forward i'm
gonna try and do my best to fulfill your
shoes um
but we'll see where everything is go
from there and
i hope we'll see you at other events
we've already talked about this and i
appreciate all the things we've been
through
astralis tried to fill the vice's
position with lucky but that wasn't
enough at least not immediately
he's got three in the round already he's
looking to close it out for rent and
there it is dijo will deliver ends they
2-0 astralis taking them down on their
map pig astralis never placed higher
than third in 2021 a decent showing for
most teams but not for astralis
meanwhile other teams took over the
spotlight for the first time in years
the final nail in astralis coffin was
the stockholm major where they bombed
out in groups placing 12th overall this
could be it for australia's three
players glaive has pulled out all the
stops zip what you got the answer's
nothing vitality two frags away from
sending astralis out of the legend stage
nade oh it's one lane
beheads him it's all on to lucky
an ak and a dream or astralis is are
left in the legend stage
no stockholm no crowd lucky trying to
kick and scream as best he can one low
shocks is on 10 hp
the rookie
trying to extend play gets the info
towards the goose position halfway he's
paranoid about long he's got to commit
now
he's the one to secure it astralis
eliminated by vitality right down to the
wire 29 rounds on dust 2. it was their
worst major performance since 2018 and
left them four spots behind device on
nip
as the major ended the writing was on
the wall the old astralis was dead
magisk and dupree bailed leaving zipnics
and glaive as the only remaining
original members of the team left but
astralis died long before the team fell
apart they died the moment that glaive
and zip took their breaks it's unclear
why but the team was never the same
after that
the astralis era ended when the pandemic
began we didn't realize it until now but
the team that defined cs go
has been gone for a long time
and yet for some reason their story
seems unfinished simple won his first
major but he didn't do it by toppling
the old gods of cs go he did it by
beating another player who spent years
getting bopped by astralis depending on
how you look at it astralis were either
cs go's greatest heroes or its greatest
villains but we never really got that
climactic ending we all hoped for no one
defeated the giants once and for all
astralis was the best team in the world
year after year they changed the way
people played cs four majors dozens of
tournament victories thousands of maps
won
and now it's all over
no big climactic finish
just a quiet fall
the era with with the five guys we've
been in astralis for so long and winning
so many things and dominating everything
just suddenly came to an end they're
kind of the gods of danish
counter-strike as you could call them so
yeah they're definitely a part of my
childhood it's a team that everyone
likes in denmark and looks up to and
wants to join one day obviously no one
can be the best forever but we have no
idea what happens next is navi going to
become the next astralis and win three
more majors can device or the new
astralis lineup even find success
with all of them scattered on different
teams they'll all have to figure out
what exactly made astralis so great was
it the world's best igl the world's most
consistent opera the world's most
dedicated fragger
or was it all of them the whole time
despite astralis collapsing their
achievements can't be understated and it
seems impossible that any team will ever
achieve the same heights they did after
all astral has changed csgo forever
twice
once when it all started and again when
it all fell apart
does that make device sasuke no
absolutely wait wait wait this works
this works right because device is
sasuke because he left the village and
glaive is naruto
that makes glaive
naruto
and
zip is sakura in that case
glee is not really the personality no
the personality doesn't match but where
they are in this placement does